president-elect joe biden preparing
to roll out the covid19 vaccine when he
takes office yesterday promising to
distribute 100 million doses
to all americans during his first 100
days in office
all the while president trump promised
to do essentially the same for americans
at his vaccine summit yesterday fox news
medical contributor dr mark siegel joins
us now
dr siegel was really remarkable
yesterday this sort of split screen that
was happening
while the president was holding that
vaccine summit explaining just how this
rollout will happen
joe biden was on other networks
unveiling the members of his
of his new team so obviously politics
plays a big part in what we're seeing
happen with the medicine side
of this pandemic so what essentially
will happen
will all americans be able to get this
vaccine
the answer to that is yes sandra you
already nailed the issue it's politics
the reality is
that both are true in other words you're
going to see probably 20 million doses
of the vaccines or or even 40 million
doses 20 million people getting
vaccinated
by the time this president leaves office
because of what you saw yesterday
the great plans that are in place with
fedex and and ups involved and with the
united states military overseeing and
everything and and with cdc and mckesson
explained themselves yesterday all of
that's happening and then joe biden
takes office
and yes i think he probably will be able
to get 100 million
doses or 100 million people even
vaccinated
in the first hundred days of his term
that's ambitious but i see both
happening
what biden will do is build on what's
already there and he doesn't want to say
that so it's going to be a combination
it's
he's basically committing to a program
that's already in place what he may do
differently
is he may look to vaccinate groups that
are being overlooked right now
or groups that we can't reach right now
right now the priorities are clearly
to get nursing homes vaccinated because
of 40 percent of the covert deaths
occurring in nursing homes and health
care workers
doctor i also want to ask you about this
these problems that have popped up in
the first day we saw the uk
vaccinate the first woman to receive it
90
years old yesterday but obviously other
people getting the first doses of the
vaccine
here's the the daily mail headline this
morning warning over uk vaccine rollout
as two nhs staff
members given jabs suffer anaphylactic
reaction
regulators are apparently urging people
with history of significant
allergies not to have the injection just
24 hours after britain's mass
inoculation kicked off
what are we hearing about this if
someone has
allergies are they supposed to not get
the vaccine for now
no sandra and i'm so glad you're
bringing this up because vaccine
hesitancy is an enormous problem in the
united states and in the world
and let's keep in mind that the pfizer
vaccine has been tested on over 20
000 people in the u.s and over 50 000
people around the world
and what that message is basically this
it's not just
allergies it's if you have a history of
what's called an
anaphylactoid reaction where you're
literally you get a big rash you start
to swell up your blood pressure goes
down that's a very big big big reaction
it's not
something where you get a little itch or
a scratch or sniffles
and people out there need to know that
this is being done
out of an abundance of caution not
because there's a great concern that
this vaccine
causes huge allergies or is a big risk
for people with allergies
very very safe vaccine is what it looks
like so far but we need to give it to
millions of people now
so important to keep the facts flowing
to the american people over this vaccine
so that more people get it dr siegel
thank you